a third-party fact check twitter went
beyond that
blocking all users including the house
judiciary committee
from sharing the article on feeds and
through direct
messages twitter even locked the new
york post
account entirely claiming the story
included
hacked materials and was potentially
harmful it is worth noting that both
twitter and facebook's aversion
to hacked materials has not always been
so
so stringent for example when the
president's tax returns were illegally
leaked neither company acted to restrict
access
to that information similarly the now
discredited steele dossier
was widely shared without fact checking
or disclaimers this apparent double
standard would be appalling under normal
circumstances
but the fact that selective censorship
is occurring
in the midst of the 2020 election cycle
dramatically amplifies the power wielded
by
facebook and twitter google recently
generated its own controversy when it
was revealed that the company
threatened to cut off several
conservative websites including the
federalists
from their ad platform
make no mistake for sites that rely
heavily on advertising revenue
for their bottom line being blocked from
google
services or demonetized
can be a death sentence according to
google the offense
of these websites was hosting user
submitted
comment sections that included
objectionable content
but google's own platform youtube hosts
user submitted comment sections for
every
video uploaded it seems that google is
far more zealous
in policing conservative sites
than its own youtube platform or the
same types
of offensive and outrageous language
it is ironic that when the subject is
net neutrality
technology companies including facebook
google and twitter have warned about the
grave threat of blocking
or throttling the flow of information on
the internet
meanwhile these same companies are
actively blocking and throttling
the distribution of content on their own
platforms and are using protections
under section 30 to do it is it any
surprise that voices on the right are
complaining about
hypocrisy or even worse
anti-democratic election interference
these recent incidents are only the
latest in long
trail of censorship and suppression of
conservative voices on the internet
reasonables or observers are left to
wonder whether big tech firms
are obstructing the flow of information
to benefit one political
ideology or agenda my concern is that
these platforms have become powerful
arbiters
of what is true and what content users
can access
the american public gets little insight
into the decision-making process
when content is moderated and users have
a little recourse when they are
censored or restricted i hope we can all
agree that
the issues committee will discuss today
are ripe
for thorough examination and
action i have introduced legislation to
clarify the intent of section 230s
liability protections and increase the
accountability of companies who engage
in content
moderation the online freedom and
viewpoint diversity act
would make important changes to
right-size the liability shield
and make clear what type of content
moderation is
protected this legislation would address
the challenges we have discussed while
still
leaving fundamentals of section 230 in
place
although some of my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle have
characterized this as
a purely partisan exercise there is
strong
bipartisan support for reviewing
section 230 in fact both presidential
candidates trump and biden
have proposed repealing section 230
in its entirety a position i have not
yet
embraced i hope we can focus today's
discussion on the issues that affect
all americans protecting a true
diversity of viewpoints
and free discourse is central to our way
of life
i look forward to hearing from today's
witnesses about what they are doing to
promote transparency accountability
and fairness in their content moderation
processes and i thank
each of them for cooperating with us
in the scheduling of this testimony and
now turn to my friend and ranking member
senator cantwell for her opening remarks
senator cantwell
the beautiful state of washington uh in
my
senate office here in washington d.c
shows the various ecosystems of the
state of washington which we very much
appreciate
i bring that up because just recently
the seattle area was named the number
one stem economy
in the united states that is the most
stem workforce in the united states of
america
so these issues about how we harness the
information age to work for us
and not against us is something that we
deal with
every day of the week and we want to
have discussion
and discourse i believe that discussion
and discourse today
should be broader than just 2 30. there
are issues of privacy that our committee
has addressed and issues
of how to make sure there is a free and
competitive
news market i noticed today we're not
calling in the nab
or the publishers association asking
them why they haven't
printed or reprinted information that
you allude to
in your testimony that you wish was more
broadly distributed
to have the competition in the news
market
is to have a diversity of voices and
diversity of opinion and in my
uh report just recently released we show
that true competition
really does help perfect information
both for our economy
and for the health of our democracy so i
do look forward to discussing
these issues today what i do not want
today's hearing to be
is a chilling effect on the very
important aspects
of making sure that hate speech
or misinformation related to health
and public safety are allowed to remain
on the internet we all know what
happened in 2016
and we had reports from the fbi our
intelligence agencies and a bipartisan
senate committee
that concluded in 2016 that russian
operatives
did masquerading as americans used
targeted advertisements
intentionally falsified news articles
self-generated content
social media platform tools to interact
and attempt to deceive
tens of millions of social media users
in the united states
director of national intelligence then
republican senator former senator dan
coats said quote in
july 2018 the warning lights are
blinking red
that the digital infrastructure that
serves our country is literally under
attack
so i take this issue very seriously and
have had
for many years that is making sure
as the moeller special counsel mueller
indicated 12 russian intelligence
officers hacked the dnc
and various information detailing
phishing attacks
into our state election boards online
personas
and stealing documents so when we had a
subcommittee hearing
and former bush homeland security
director michael chertoff testified
i asked him point blank because there
were some of our colleagues who were
saying you know what everybody does
election interference
so i asked him if election interference
was something that we did or should
be encouraging he responded that he
agreed
quote interfering with infrastructure or
elections is completely off limits
and unacceptable that is why i believe
that
we should be working aggressively
internationally
to sanction anybody that interferes in
our elections
so i hope today that we will get a
report
from the witnesses on exactly what they
have been doing
to clamp down on election interference i
hope that they will tell us
what kind of hate speech and
misinformation that they have taken off
the books
it is no secret that there are various
state actors
who are doing all they can to take a
whack at democracy
to try to say that our way of government
that our way of life that our way of
freedom of speech and information
is somehow not as good as we have made
it
being the beacon of democracy around the
globe
i am not going to let or tolerate people
to continue to whack
at our election process our vote by mail
system
or the ability of tech platforms
security companies our law enforcement
entities
and the collective community to speak
against
misinformation and hate speech we have
to show that the united states of
america stands behind our principles
and that our principles do also transfer
to the responsibility of communication
online
as my colleagues will know we've all
been through this in the past that is
why
you mr chairman and i and senators rosen
and thune sponsored the hacked act
that is to help increase the security
and cyber security of our nation
and create a workforce that can fight
against that that is why i joined with
van hollen and rubio on the deter
act especially establishing sanctions
against russian election interference
and to continue to make sure that we
build the infrastructure
of tomorrow so i know that some people
think that these issues
are out of sight and out of mind i
guarantee you they're not
there are actors who have been at this
for a long time
they wanted to destabilize eastern
europe and we became the second act when
they tried to destabilize
our democracy here by sowing
disinformation
i want to show them that we in the
united states
do have fair elections we do have a fair
process
we are going to be that beacon of
democracy
so i hope that as we talk about 230
today and we hear from the witnesses on
the progress that they have made
in making sure that disinformation is
not allowed online
that we will also consider ways to help
build and strengthen that
that is to say as some of those who are
testifying today
what can we do on transparency on
reporting
on analysis and yes i think you're going
to hear a lot about algorithms today
and and the kind of oversight that we
all want
to make sure that we can continue to
have a diversity of voices
in the united states of america both
online
and offline i do want to say though mr
chairman i am
concerned about the vertical nature of
news and information today i expect to
ask
the witnesses about the fact that i
believe they create a choke point for
local
news the local news media have lost 70
percent of their revenue
over the last decade and we have lost
thousands
thousands of journalistic jobs that are
important
it was even amazing to me that the
sequence of events
yesterday had me being interviewed
by someone at a newspaper who was funded
by a joint group of the knight
foundation
and probably facebook funds to interview
me
about the fact that the news media and
broadcast has fallen on such a decline
because of loss of revenue as they've
made the transition to the digital age
somehow somehow we have to come together
to show that the diversity of voices
that local news represent
need to be dealt with fairly when it
comes to the advertising market
and that too much control in the
advertising market puts a foot on the on
their ability to continue to move
forward and grow in the digital age
just as other forms of media have made
the transition
and yes still making the transition we
want to have
a very healthy and dynamic news media
across the united states of america
so i plan to ask the witnesses today
about that
i wish we had time to go into depth on
privacy and privacy issues but mr
chairman you know
and so does senator thune and other
colleagues of the committee on my side
how important it is that we protect
america consumers on privacy issues
but we're not done with this work that
there is much to do to bring consensus
in the united states on this important
issue and i hope that as we do have time
or in the follow-up to these questions
that we can uh ask the witnesses about
that today
but make no mistake gentlemen thank you
for joining us
but this is probably uh one of many many
many conversations
that we will have about all of these
issues but again
let's harness the information age as you
are doing
but let's also make sure that consumers
are fairly treated
and that we are making it work for all
of us to guarantee our privacy
our diversity of divorces and upholding
our democratic principles
and the fact that we the united states
of america
stand for freedom of information and
freedom of the press
thank you thank you senator cantwell and
certainly you're correct
that this uh will not be the last um
hearing with regard to this subject
matter and i also
appreciate you mentioning your concerns
which i share
about local journalism
at this point we
are about to receive testimony from our
witnesses before we begin that
let me remind members that today's
hearing
will provide senators with seven minute
rounds uh uh with a round of seven
minute uh
questioning rather than the usual five
minutes
that we um have uh done in the past
at at seven minutes the gavel will um
let's say that at a few seconds after
seven minutes the gavel will go down
even so this hearing uh could
last some three hours and 42 minutes at
that rate so
um this will be an extensive
and lengthy hearing members are advised
that we will adhere closely
to that seven minute limit and also
shortly before noon at the request of
one of our witnesses
we will take a short 10 minute break
with that
we welcome our panel of witnesses thank
them for their testimony and ask them
to give their opening statements
summarizing them in some
five minutes the entire statement will
be
added at this point in the record and we
will begin
with mr jack dorsey of twitter sir are
you
um here do you hear us and uh we have
contact with you
yes can you hear me yes yes um so thank
you for being with us and you are now
recognized for five minutes sir
okay thank you members of the commerce
committee for the opportunity to speak
with the american people
about twitter and section 230. my
remarks will be brief
so we can get to questions section 230
is the most
important law protecting internet speech
and removing section 230 will remove
speech from the internet
section 230 gave internet services two
important tools
the first provides immunity from
liability for users content
the second provides good samaritan
protections
for content moderation and removal even
of constitutionally protected speech
as long as it's done in good faith
that concept of good faith is what's
being challenged by many of you today
some of you don't trust we're acting in
good faith that's the problem
i want to focus on solving how does
services like twitter
earn your trust how do we ensure more
choice in the market
if we don't there are three solutions
we'd like to propose
to address the concerns raised all
focused on services that decide
to moderate or remove content it could
be expansions
to section 230 new legislative
frameworks
or commitment to industry-wide
self-regulation best practices
the first is requiring a services
moderation process to be published
our cases reported and reviewed our
decisions made
what tools are used to enforce
publishing answers to questions like
these will make our process more robust
and accountable to the people we serve
the second is requiring a
straightforward process to appeal
decisions
made by humans or by algorithms
this ensures people can let us know when
we don't get it right
so we can fix any mistakes and make our
processes better
in the future and finally much of the
content people see today
is determined by algorithms with very
little visibility
into how they choose what they show we
took a first step
in making this more transparent by
building a button to turn off our home
timeline algorithms it's a good start
but we're inspired by the market
approach suggested by dr stephen wolfram
before this committee in june 2019
enabling people to choose algorithms
created by third parties to rank
and filter their content is an
incredibly energizing idea
that's in reach requiring
one moderation process and practices to
be published
two a straightforward process to appeal
decisions
and three best efforts around
algorithmic choice
are suggestions to address the concerns
we all have going forward
and they're all achievable in short
order
it's critical as we consider these
solutions we optimize for new startups
and independent developers doing so
ensures a level playing field
that increases the probability of
competing ideas to help solve problems
we must entrench the largest companies
any further
thank you for the time and i look
forward to a productive discussion to
dig into these
and other ideas
thank you very much mr dorsey we now
uh call on mr sundar pika
you are recognized for five minutes sir
chairman liquor ranking member campbell
and distinguished members of the
committee
thank you for the opportunity to appear
before you today
the internet has been a powerful force
for good
over the past three decades has
radically improved access to information
whether it's connecting americans to
jobs getting critical updates to people
in times of crisis or helping a parent
find answers to questions like
how can i get my baby to sleep through
the night
at the same time people everywhere can
use their voices to share new
perspectives
express themselves and reach broader
audiences
than ever before whether you're a barber
in mississippi
or a home renovator in indiana you can
share a video
and build a global fan base and a
successful business
right from your living room in this way
the internet has been one of the world's
most important equalizers
information can be shared and knowledge
can flow
from anyone to anywhere the same low
barriers to entry
also make it possible for bad actors to
cause harm
as a company whose mission is to
organize the world's information
and make it universally accessible and
useful
google is deeply conscious of both the
opportunities
and risks the internet creates i'm proud
that google's information services
like search gmail maps and photos
provide thousands of dollars a year in
value to the average american
for free we feel a deep responsibility
to keep the people who use our products
safe and secure and have long invested
in innovative tools to prevent abuse of
our services
when it comes to privacy we are
committed to keeping your information
safe treating it responsibly and putting
you in control
we continue to make privacy improvements
like the changes i
announced earlier this year to keep less
data by default
and support the creation of
comprehensive federal privacy laws
we are equally committed to protecting
the quality and integrity of information
on our platforms
and supporting our democracy in a
non-partisan way
as just one timely example our
information panels on google and youtube
inform users about where to vote and how
to register
we've also taken many steps to raise up
high quality journalism
from sending 24 billion visits to news
websites globally every month
to our recent one billion dollar
investment in partnerships with news
publishers
since our founding we've been deeply
committed to the freedom of expression
we also feel a responsibility to protect
people who use our products from harmful
content
and to be transparent about how we do
that
that's why we set and publicly disclose
clear guidelines for our products and
platforms
which we enforce impartially
we recognize that people come to our
services with a broad spectrum of
perspectives
and we are dedicated to building
products that are helpful to users
of all backgrounds and viewpoints let me
be clear
we approach our work without political
bias full stop
to do otherwise would be contrary to
both our business interests
and our mission which compels us to make
information
accessible to every type of person no
matter where they live or what they
believe
of course our ability to provide access
to a wide range of information
is only possible because of existing
legal frameworks
like section 230. the united states
adopted section 230 early in the
internet's history
and it has been foundational to us
leadership in the tech sector
it protects the freedom to create and
share content while supporting the
ability of platforms and services
of all sizes to responsibly address
harmful content
we appreciate that this committee has
put great thought into how platforms
should address content
we look forward to having these
conversations
as you think about how to shape policy
in this important area
i would urge the committee to be very
thoughtful about any changes to section
230
and to be very aware of the consequences
those changes might have on businesses
and customers at the end of the day we
all share the same goal
free access to information for everyone
and responsible predictions
for people and their data we support
legal frameworks that achieve these
goals
i look forward to engaging with you
today about these important issues
and answering your questions thank you
thank you very much mr pakai pakkai
members should be advised at this point
that we are unable
to make contact with mr mark zuckerberg
we're told by facebook staff that he
is alone um and
uh attempting to
to connect with his hearing and
that they are requesting a five-minute
recess at this point uh to see if that
connection can be made
i think this is um
most a most interesting development but
we're going to accommodate the request
of uh
the facebook um
employees and uh and to see if within
five minutes
we can make contact
and proceed so at this point declare a
five-minute recess
is
oh
yes
call the hearing back into order and
we're told that in
in less than five minutes we have
success
so um mr zuckerberg i'm told
that we have both video and audio
connection
are you there sir uh yes i am can you
hear me
can hear you fine and you're now
recognized for five minutes to
summarize your testimony welcome all
right
thank you chairman um i was able to hear
the other the other opening statements
um i was just having a hard time
connecting
myself um all right so i know the
feeling
mr zuckerberg chairman wicker
ranking member kentwell and members of
the committee
every day millions of americans use the
internet to share their experiences and
discuss issues that matter to them
setting the rules for online discourse
is an important challenge for our
society
and there are principles at stake that
go beyond any one platform
how do we balance free expression and
safety how do we define what is
dangerous
who should decide i don't believe that
private companies should be making so
many decisions about these issues by
themselves
and at facebook we often have to balance
competing equities
sometimes the best approach from a
safety or security perspective isn't the
best
for privacy or free expression so we
work with experts across society to
strike the right balance
we don't always get it right but we try
to be fair and consistent
the reality is that people have very
different
ideas and views about where the lines
should be
democrats often say that we don't remove
enough content and republicans often say
we remove too much i expect that we'll
hear some of those
criticisms today and the fact that both
sides
criticize us doesn't mean that we're
getting this right but it does mean
that there are real disagreements about
where the limits of online speech
should be and i think that's
understandable people can reasonably
disagree
about where to draw the lines that's a
hallmark
of democratic societies especially here
in the u.s with our strong first
amendment tradition
but it strengthens my belief that when a
private company
is making these calls we need a more
accountable process
that people feel is legitimate and that
gives platforms certainty
at facebook we publish our standards and
issue
quarterly reports on the content that we
take down
we launched an independent oversight
board that can overturn our decisions
and we've committed to an audit of our
content reports
but i believe congress has a role to
play too in order to give people
confidence that the process is carried
out
in a way that balances society's deeply
held values appropriately and that's
why i've called for regulation right now
the discussion is focused on section
230.
some say that ending 230 would solve all
of the internet's problems
others say it would end the internet as
we know it
from our perspective section 230 does
two basic things
first it encourages free expression
which is fundamentally important
without 230 platforms could potentially
be held liable
for everything that people say they'd
face much greater pressure
to take down more content to avoid legal
risk
second if platform it allows platforms
to moderate content
without 230 platforms could face
liability for basic moderation like
removing harassment
that impacts the safety of their
communities
now there's a reason why america leads
in technology
section 230 helped create the internet
as we know it
it has helped new ideas get built and
our companies to spread american values
around the world and we should maintain
this advantage
but the internet has also evolved and i
think that congress
should update the law to make sure that
it's working as intended
one important place to start would be
making content moderation systems more
transparent
another would be to separate good actors
from bad actors by
making sure that companies can't hide
behind section 230
to avoid responsibility for
intentionally facilitating illegal
activity on their platforms
we're open to working with congress on
these ideas and more
i hope the changes that you make will
ring true to the spirit and intent of
230
there are consequential choices to make
here and it's important that we
don't prevent the next generation of
ideas from being built
now although this hearing is about
content policy i also want to cover our
election preparedness work
voting ends in six days we're in the
midst of a pandemic
and there are ongoing threats to the
integrity of this election
since 2016 facebook has made major
investments
to stop foreign interference we've hired
more than 35 000 people
to work on safety and security we've
disrupted more than 100
networks coming from russia iran
and china and more there were misleading
people about who they are
and what they're doing including three
just this week
this is an extraordinary election and
we've updated our policies to reflect
that
we're showing people reliable
information about voting and results
and we've strengthened our ads and
misinformation policies
we're also running the largest voting
information campaign in u.s history
we estimate that we've helped more than
4.4 million people register to vote
and a hundred thousand people volunteer
to be poll workers
candidates on both sides continue to use
our platforms
to reach voters and people are rightly
focused on the role that technology
companies play in our elections
i'm proud of the work that we've done to
support our democracy
this is a difficult period but i believe
that america will emerge stronger than
ever
and we're focused on doing our part to
help
well thank you thank you very much mr
zuckerberg and thanks to
all of our witnesses we will now i think
we're supposed to set the clock to
seven minutes and i see five minutes up
there but
somehow we'll we'll um we'll keep time
so
there we are okay um but well thank you
all
um let me start then um with mr dorsey
um mr dorsey the committee has compiled
dozens and dozens of examples
of um conservative content being
censored and suppressed by your
platforms
over over the last four years i i
entered these examples into the record
on october 1st when the committee
voted unanimously to issue
the subpoenas and and thank you all
three again for working with us
on the scheduling um
[Music]
alleviating uh the necessity for
actually exercising the subpoenas
um mr dorsey your platform allows
foreign dictators to post
propaganda typically without restriction
yet you routinely restrict the president
of the united states
and here's an example in march a
spokesman for the chinese communist
party falsely accused the u.s military
of causing the coronavirus epidemic
he tweeted quote cdc was
caught on the spot when did patient zero
begin
in the u.s how many people are infected
what are the names of the hospitals it
might be the u.s
army who brought the epidemic
to wuhan and on and on
after this tweet was up for some two
months
twitter added a fact check label to this
tweet after
being up for two months however when
president
trump tweeted about how
mail-in ballots are vulnerable to fraud
a statement that
i subscribe to and agree with in a
statement that isn't
in in fact true twitter immediately
imposed fact check label on that
tweet mr dorsey how does it claim by
chinese communists
that the u.s military is to blame for
covid
remain up for two months without a fact
check and the president's tweet
about security mail and ballots get
labeled instantly
well first and foremost we as you
mentioned we did label
that tweet um as we think about
enforcement
we consider severity of offline
of potential offline harm and we act
as quickly as we can we have taken
action
against tweets from world leaders all
around the world
including the president and we did
take action on that tweet because we saw
it
we saw the confusion it might encourage
and we labeled it accordingly and the
goal with our labeling
speaking of the president's tweet yes
okay the goal of our labeling is to
provide
more context to connect the dots uh so
that people can have more information
so they can make decisions for
themselves we
you know we we've created these policies
recently
we are enforcing them um there are
certainly
things that we can do much faster
but generally um we believe that the
policy was enforced in a timely manner
and uh in the right regard and and
and yet uh you seem to have no objection
to um a tweet by the chinese communist
party saying
the us army brought the epidemic to
wuhan
well we did and we we labeled that tweet
um
providing providing two months to do so
is that correct
i'm not sure of the exact time frame but
we can get back to you on that
so uh you're going to get back to us as
to how
a tweet from the chinese communist party
falsely accusing
the u.s military of causing the corona
virus epidemic
was uh was left up for two months
with with no comment from from twitter
while uh the president of the united
states
um making a statement about being
careful about
the voter about ballot security
with the mail was labeled immediately
i uh i have a tweet here
from mr ajit pai
mr ajit pai is the is the chairman of
the federal
communications commission and
um and and he
he he recounts some four tweets
by the iranian dictator
ayatollah ali khamenei which
twitter did not place a public label on
they all four of them glorify violence
the first tweet says this and i quote
each time
the zionist regime is a deadly cancerous
growth and a detriment to the region it
will undoubtedly be uprooted and
destroyed
that's the first tweet the second tweet
the only remedy until the removal of the
zionist regime
is firm armed resistance again
left up without comment
by twitter the third the struggle to
free
palestine is jihad
in the way of god um
i quote i quote that in part for
the sake of time and number four we will
support and assist
any nation or any group anywhere who
opposes and fights
the zionist regime i um
i would simply point out that um
these tweets are still up mr dorsey
and uh how is it that they are
acceptable
to be to be there i'll i'll ask
unanimous consent
to enter this tweet from ajit pai and
the record at this point that will be
done without objection
how mr dorsey is that acceptable
based on your policies at twitter
we believe it's important for everyone
to hear from global leaders
um and we have uh policies
around world leaders um we want to make
sure that
we are respecting their right to speak
uh and and to publish what they need
but if there is a violation of our terms
of service uh we want to label it
and they're still up do they violate
your terms of service mr dorsey
we we did not find those to violate our
terms of service
because we considered them saber
rattling which is
um is part of the speech of world
leaders
in in concert with other countries um
speech
uh against our own people
or a country's own citizens we believe
is different and can cause
more immediate harm very very telling
information mr dorsey thank you very
much senator cantwell you are recognized
i think i'm referring to our colleague
senator uh peters just because of timing
and
situation for him all right senator
peters are you there
i am here i am here you are recognized
for seven minutes
well thank you mr chairman and uh
ranking member canwell
appreciate uh uh your deferral to me i
certainly
appreciate uh that consideration a great
deal
also want to thank each of our panelists
here today
for coming forward and being a witness
and appreciate
all of you accommodating your schedule
so that we could have this uh hearing
my first uh question uh is for mr uh
zuckerberg um
as and i want to start off by saying how
much i appreciated our opportunity
uh last night uh to speak at length on a
number of issues and
as i told you last night i i appreciate
the facebook's efforts
to assist the law enforcement to disrupt
a plot to
kidnap and then to hold a sham trial
and and kill our governor governor
whitmer
the individuals in that case uh
apparently uh
used the facebook for a broad recruiting
effort but then
they actually plan the specifics of that
operation
off off of your platform my question is
when users
reach the level of radicalization that
violates your community
standards you often will ban those
groups and your then drive them off to
other platforms
those platforms tend to have less
transparency and oversight
but the the issue that i'd like you to
address is for those
individuals that remain on your platform
they they're often far down the path of
uh
radicalization but they are definitely
looking uh for an outlet
and i understand that facebook has
recently adopted a strategy to redirect
users who are searching for example uh
for election misinformation
uh but it doesn't seem to that policy
applies to
budding violent uh extremists uh mr
zuckerberg you do you believe that that
the platform
as a your platform has a responsibility
to off-ramp users who are
on the path to radicalization by violent
uh extremist groups
senator thanks for the the question i
think this is
very important and my understanding is
that we actually do
a little of what you're you're talking
about here if people are searching for
um you know i think for example white
supremacist organizations of which we
we ban those we treat them as as
terrorist organizations
um you know not only are we not going to
show that content but i think we try to
um where we can highlight
um information that would be helpful and
i think we try to work with experts on
that i
um i can i can follow up and get you
more information on the scope of those
activities and when we
invoke that but i certainly agree with
the spirit of the question that this is
a good idea and something that we should
continue uh
pursuing and perhaps expand well i
appreciate those comments i'm the
ranking member
on senate homeland security committee
and what we're are seeing is a rise of
violent uh extremist groups which is uh
very troubling and certainly
we need to work very closely with you as
to how do we disrupt this kind of
radicalization especially folks that are
using your platform so i appreciate
the opportunity to work further and and
as we talked about last night you
asserted that facebook is
proactively working with law enforcement
now to disrupt
some of these real world violent
attempts
that stem from some of that activity
that originated your platform
could you tell me specifically how many
threats
that you have proactively referred to
local or state law enforcement
prior to being approached for a
preservation
request senator i don't know the number
off the top of my head um so i can
follow up with you on that but
um it is increasingly common that our
systems are able to
detect when there's potential issues
and over the last four years in
particular we've built closer
partnerships with law enforcement and
the intelligence community to be able to
share those kind of signals
so we're doing more of that including in
the case that you mentioned before
um around the the attempted uh
kidnapping of governor
whitmer we we identified that as a
signal to the fbi
um i think it was about six months ago
uh when we started seeing some
some suspicious activity on our platform
and um there's certainly
that's that's part of our our routine
and and how we operate
well uh mr berg discovery tools um and
recommendation algorithms that your
platforms
use does serve up potentially extremist
content
based on the user profiles of folks
uh as we as we seek to understand why
membership in these extremist groups as
our
rise is rising uh i would hope that your
companies are
right now engaging in some forensic
analysis of membership
once you take down an extremist group to
take a look at how that uh happened on
your platform
it's certainly going to better inform us
as to how we can disrupt
this type of recruitment into extremist
groups
my question for you though is that in in
2016 you said and this was
apparently an internal facebook internal
document that was reported by the wall
street journal
that said that 64 of members of violent
groups became members because of your
platform's recommendation
uh and i'll quote from that report that
was reported in the wall street journal
it said our recommendation systems grow
the problem that's clearly very
concerning and i know in response to
that report in 2016 you had made changes
to your policies you made changes
to some of the algorithms that existed
at that time
my question is have you seen a reduction
in your platform's facilitation of
extremist
group recruitment since the those
policies were changed
senator i'm not familiar with that
specific study but i agree with the
concern
and making sure that our recommendation
systems
for what groups uh people are are
given the opportunity to join is
certainly one important
uh vector for for addressing this issue
and we've taken a number
of steps here including disqualifying
groups from being included in our
recommendation system at all
if they routinely are being used to
share misinformation or if they have uh
content violations
um or a number of other criteria so
um i i'm quite focused on this i agree
with
with um where you're going with with
that question
um i i don't have any data today on
um the the real world impact of that yet
but i
i think that addressing this upstream is
is very important
so uh i appreciate you agreeing uh with
that and that we need more data
is it that you don't have the data just
at the top of your head
or that it doesn't uh exist
uh well senator certainly the former
and and um potentially the latter as
well i think it probably takes
um some time before after we make these
changes
uh to be able to measure the the impact
of it
um and i'm not aware of of what
um studies are going on into this this
is it seems like the type of thing that
one would want uh not just internal
facebook researchers to work on
uh but also potentially a collaboration
with with um
independent academics as well thank you
mr zuckerberg and thank you thank you
senator peters
senator gardner um has also asked to
go out of order and senator thune has
graciously deferred to him so senator
gardner senator
you are recognized for uh for seven
minutes sir
well thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator thune for
for sharing your time or at least
deferring your time to me
and thank you mr zuckerberg mr pj thank
you very much and mr dorsey thank you
for being here uh mr dorsey i'm going to
direct these first
questions to you mr dorsey do you
believe that the holocaust really
happened yes or no
yes so you would agree that someone who
says the holocaust
may not have happened is spreading
misinformation yes or no
uh yes i appreciate your answers on this
but they surprised me and probably a lot
of
other colorads and americans after all
iran's ayatollah has done
exactly this questioning the holocaust
and yet his tweets remain unflagged on
twitter's
platform you and i agree that moderating
your platform makes sense in certain
respects
we don't want the next terrorist finding
inspiration on twitter
or any certain any platform for that
matter
but you've also decided to moderate
certain content from
influential world leaders i'd like to
understand your decisions to do so a
little bit better
can you name any other instance of
twitter hiding or deleting
a tweet from heads of state uh
not not off the top of my head but we
have many examples across world leaders
around the world would you be willing to
provide a list of those
absolutely uh i know we've established
we agree content moderation can have
certain upsides like
combating terrorism but twitter has
chosen to approach content moderation
from the standpoint of
combating misinformation as well so it's
strange to me that you've flagged the
tweets from
the president but haven't hidden the
ayatollah's tweets on
holocaust denial or calls to wipe israel
off the map
and that you you can't recall off the
top of your head hidden or deleted
tweets from other world leaders i would
appreciate that
uh that list i think it's important that
we all hear that so that brings my next
question uh to the front does twitter
maintain a formal list of certain
accounts
that you actively monitor for
misinformation
no and we don't have a policy against
misinformation we have a policy
against misinformation in three
categories which are manipulated media
public health specifically covet and
civic integrity
election and election interference and
voter suppression
that is all we have policy on for
misleading information
we do not have policy or enforcement for
any other types
of misleading information that you're
mentioning so somebody denying the
murder of millions of people
or instigating violence against a
country as a head of state
is not categorically falling in any of
those three
misinformation or other categories
twitter has not misinformation but we do
have other policies
around incitement to violence uh which
which may
um some some of the tweets you mentioned
or the examples that you're mentioning
uh may fall follow but for misleading
information uh we're focused on those
three categories only
so somebody denies the holocaust has
happened is not misinformation
it's it's misleading information but we
don't have a policy against that type of
misleading information
millions of people died and that's not
a violation of twitter again i just
don't understand
how you can label a president of the
united states
have you ever taken a tweet down from
the i told it
uh i i believe we have but we can get
back to you on it we've certainly
labeled tweets
um and i believe we have taken one down
as well
um you know if you if you you said you
do not have a list is that correct you
do not maintain a list
we don't maintain a list of accounts we
watch we look for reports
uh and issues brought to us and then we
weigh it against our policy and enforce
if needed you look
for reports from your employees or from
the
no from the people from the people using
the service
right and then they they turn that over
to your your board of
review is that correct we we
well so in some cases algorithms take
action
uh in other cases achievements do in
some cases it's a pairing of the two
there are numerous examples of blue
check marks uh blue check marks that are
spreading false information that aren't
flagged so
twitter must have some kind of list of
priority accounts that it maintains you
have the
blue check mark list how do you decide
how do you decide when to flag a tweet
you got into that a little bit is there
a formal threshold of retweets or likes
that must be met before
a tweet is flagged no
twitter can't claim that uh i i just
with your answers on
the itola and others i just don't
understand how twitter can claim to
want a world of less hate and
misinformation while you simultaneously
let the kind of content that the
ayatollah has
tweeted out flourish on the platform
including from uh other world leaders
i i just it's no wonder that americans
are concerned about politically
motivated content moderation at twitter
given what we have just said i don't
like the idea of a group of
unelected elites in san francisco or
silicon valley deciding
whether my speech is permissible on
their platforms but i like that
even less the idea of unelected
washington dc bureaucrats trying to
enforce some kind of politically neutral
content moderation so
just as we have heard from other
panelists as we we're going to hear
throughout the day
we have to be very careful uh and not
rush to legislate in ways that stifle
speech
you can delete facebook turn off twitter
or try to ditch google that you cannot
unsubscribe
from government censors congress should
be focused on encouraging speech not
restricting it
the supreme court has tried teaching us
that lesson time and time again and the
constitution demands
that we remember it i'm running short on
time so i'm going to very quickly
go through another question one of the
core ideas of section 230s liability
protections is this you shouldn't be
responsible for what someone else says
on your platform
conversely you should be liable for what
you say or do
on your own platform i think that's
pretty common sense but courts have not
always agreed with this rep
this approach even uh rep chris cox
opined in a recent wall street journal
uh op-ed that section 230 has sometimes
been interpreted by courts more broadly
than
i expected for example allowing some
websites to escape liability
for content they helped create mr
zuckerberg i have a simple question for
you and each of the panelists today
quickly uh to be clear i'm not talking
about technical tools or operating
the platform itself here i'm purely
talking about content do you agree
that internet platform should be held
liable for the specific content that you
yourself create on your own platforms
yes or no very quickly
uh senator i think that that is
reasonable uh yes or no mr dorsey
if twitter creates specific content
should twitter be liable for that
content
series mr peachey same question to you
yes or no should google be liable for
the specific content that it creates
uh if we are acting as a publisher i
would i would uh
say yes the specific content that you
create on your own platform
yes that seems reasonable uh thank you i
think one of the other sides of
liability questions in regards to the
good faith removal
provision in section 230 that we'll get
into a little bit more in the private
questions i know i'm out of time so mr
chairman thank you for
uh giving me this time senator thune
thank you as well and thanks to the
witnesses
thank you senator gardner
the ranking member has now deferred to
senator klobuchar so
um